Stables
[Applause]
I'm so happy to see you in person
I'm so honored that you came you you
emanate such light and goodness and
beauty and Grace I'm just so happy to be
uh in person with you because
and
I've been such a fan of yours for so
well forever and and well it's just
someone that I admire so much who I
would be saying all this to go ahead um
great
first of all the clip that you came out
with Alice in Wonderland like was it a
cool project was it a nice job were you
like psyched that was with Harvey Korman
you know that other guy there and I've
had I don't know if you have two
probably we've just been able to run
into and work with some of the greatest
legends of all time and but while we're
working with them we don't realize oh my
God that's you know I lost my dear
friend Bob recently and just like every
moment is just so precious to me now
I was actually watching um I was looking
at photos of you and Candace Cameron and
you're doing a concert with the Beach
Boys and Candace comes up and there's a
tribute to Bob Saget will you tell me
about that well I I um I've been doing a
lot of tribute to him since he passed
away
um
and I'm sure he's if we're real quiet we
can hear him complaining that I don't
talk about him enough in heaven but I do
a piece in the show where I sing a song
Forever that I did on Full House and I
play a really beautiful clip of him I
found this audio of him just talking
about you know being good to people and
being nice to people and he's got and he
says I've had a lot of love in my life
and a lot of laughter and I wish that
for you and so I play that and they'll
be sing a song
I I love that you are you know so
present about him I have so many
beautiful last little texts and our last
dinner together was so special and he
wrote this beautiful post about me being
his brother and one of the big heart
breaks for me when he died was that it
was a tsunami of love for him this
outpouring of love for him he and I
don't think he knew how loved he was and
it was just it was beautiful to see all
these people saying all these wonderful
things about him but I just felt so bad
that he couldn't be there to hear it and
so on the show on Big Shot I have this
new show on Disney plus which I love so
much
it's so wonderful it's like oh my gosh
and season two is like already getting
Stellar reviews well that's sweet I mean
well okay we have a clip here let's show
a clip from Big Shot
relax we're almost tension together
plenty of time to talk we might as well
make the best of it wait are you not I
thought that you would be more mad oh
I'm mad no I'm plenty mad about the
cricket thing you'll be running that off
for a while
but I love that you did it for Emma it
was very sweet
which reminds me I have a question for
you guys
why are boys just the worst
tell me about
[Applause]
tell me about your girls eight and ten
they are now eight and a half Frankie
yeah ten Olive my boy's four and a half
can I ask you a parenting question
please how did you keep them alive
my kid is just you know well boys they
are rough and tumble like girls have a
whole other set of like things to
contend with and issues but little boys
yeah I don't know how we keep them alive
I know he's pretty he I talked to him
yesterday he's he says he likes to say
poop all the time now that's it
um and then last night was a beautiful
and I called him on FaceTime and um I
said he's on Michigan and I said go go
out I was on the balcony I said go
outside look at the Moon son and he went
outside the blood moon he was beautiful
right and I said go look at him I said
you see that Moon he said yeah Dad I
said that's the same Moon that I'm
looking at right now and he said I can
see your eyes dad and I said I could see
your eyes too son it was like this very
touching moment and I said I love you
Billy he said I love you poopy
okay it's like
it was like you reeled me and like
ripples used to do you know he just
reeled me in real I love you is it true
I'm already married no I know you are
I'm I'm like but you have letters from
your mom like I was reading and
researching that about you and I I don't
think there's any more profound way to
communicate with your loved ones like
there is
I write postcards to my daughters all
the time they have stamp collections we
have letters beautiful I I um my mom was
great with it and she wrote These great
notes and I remember I was cleaning out
her house it was about a month or so
after she passed away and it was my
roughest moment and I looked over and I
I saw this note and she wrote she said
life is an occasion rise to it don't be
sad because I died be happy because I
lived I had a wonderful life
that was my mom
[Applause]
is it true that you kept the red doors
from Full House
I stole a lot of things from that show
for most shows I always did did you take
stuff from the set oh that's yeah I'm an
idiot who didn't take I think you should
have taken E.T that would have been a
good one
[Applause]
we were building a bathroom on our house
and I said oh I have these old doors
from Full House where we put those but
every time I go every time I walk out of
the bathroom I expect people to clap and
Applause and they're like you know when
you make an insurance on a sitcom I mean
that is so crazy that you have that
retro there's a couch too I don't know
you're on the couch yeah the original
couch oh my God that should be in like a
museum do you want to buy it
but I'm like let's talk price during the
commercial break
um and wasn't it Sammy Davis Jr that
like got you into music and drums and
instruments yeah I was I wanted to play
drums on on the soap opera I just
started I was 18 and he was singing and
there was a stage and with a full band
and stuff and my I said to my dad who's
Sammy Davis Jr said played the record
and said I said what do I talk to him
about he plays drums I'm talking about
drums I said okay uh Mr Davis Jr I want
to play drums on here and they won't let
me you know okay let me you know just do
what I say man so he gets I introduce
him as the character he gets up and he
goes uh black you played drums right and
I'm like yeah it's all ad-lib I go yeah
he goes come on she said
he's playing piano and it was one of the
most important moments of my life
because from then on I played music you
know until today
[Music]